in college yes definitely but then as a
teacher probably the most one hi I'm
Vanessa and I'm a teacher
hi I'm Bryant and I'm a teen today we
are playing never have I ever never have
I ever cheated on a test yeah really
yeah what test was it it was in probably
in seventh grade math test you know I
think I was having trouble remembering a
formula so just wrote it on my eraser
flip the eraser upside down I think was
on a history test I might have like
peeked over oh wow
then they have the right answer though
that's the question probably not I'm
really smart so I'm not never have I
ever worked with someone who I've hated
with a burning fire of a thousand suns I
mean this one's easy I mean come on that
really it's a strong word maybe not with
the fire of a thousand bernie & sons'
maybe a few a few signs yes but like
what oh yeah
just Jessie wait no it's just one day
you're gonna wake up and you're gonna
realize the people you work with are the
scum of humanity I don't doubt that when
I was working as a tutor we decided to
do like two on Tuesday or like there'd
be two tutors and two tooties and the
other tutor was just I couldn't stand
him and I had to be in a different room
like I couldn't take it I wouldn't say
that about a student because I don't
know so much can be really annoying
that's true but there's a difference
between being annoyed and hatred and I
feel hatred my teacher goes ballistic
never have I ever lied about a family
member being sick to get out of two
something I think I said you know I had
to take my mom to the doctor or
something like that or I don't know I
don't think I have I think I'd probably
say I was the sick one rather than like
Manny you know it's like it's like
looking at your future never have I ever
made up a lesson plan or a class
presentation on the spot putting mine up
sideways because I have definitely
created a lesson plan last minute like
nail biter situation like finishing my
presentation about 20 minutes before
class started once it went well that's
why I keep telling myself anything
pretty much all the time I'm a preschool
teacher so we just kind of have to bring
things out as you need them you know we
call it our little bag of tricks I just
have a lot of anxiety so if I'm not
prepared then I'll just have a meltdown
yeah that's true I also have a lot of
anxiety so I was having a meltdown while
creating a lesson plan which was just a
great combination sounds like fun it
wasn't never have I ever gone out on a
school night and regretted it the next
day
really oh yeah 100% well as a teacher we
like to party and I've definitely had
those mornings with the crazy
preschoolers screaming in my ears with a
splitting headache I just swore it was
gonna be the last time it's probably
gonna happen again
yeah well in high school no not so much
I was kind of boring in college yes
definitely but then as a teacher
probably the most some times somebody's
getting married and you sort of wake up
the next day and you're making a lesson
plan 20 minutes before to do and anyway
never have I ever gossiped about a
teacher I didn't like yeah of course
okay maybe not too much though I try not
to gossip try not to get wrapped up in
that that world I had a teacher not who
I worked with this is when I was still a
student who whose nickname was a a B I'm
not gonna say his last name the reason
he was called that was because you got
an A if you showed up and Abby
if you did it like the class Hey well
here's here's the turning point of that
story he had found out about that
nickname before I was one of his
students and then he was like oh well
now I'm just gonna be like one of the
toughest teachers there is and I got
like a c-minus in his class no you went
every single time I wanted to agree with
it firmly oh yeah I probably have it's
probably like you know the school
culture of just teens talking to other
teens about what they like what they
don't like about teachers and I'm sure
it's come up in situations I had a
teacher who he would take our grades and
post them on the door
really and so we would all crowder on
the door and like we would judge each
other
it's not the school plate there were
probably students who failed that class
right I think he did put a like a
failure line that's that's crazy that's
crazy to me I would never do that I
student top five though there you go
that's that's what's important with the
story that's boggers really never have I
ever lied to principal no not really
I don't think like and high school or
anything I was really like called to the
principal's office
okay good to know I think there was one
time when I was in like seventh grade
that we knew we shouldn't be in the
auditorium but we snuck in there anyway
then the principal came in so I remember
just trying to talk my way out of it
like oh no like we were trying to help
get something ready or I don't know what
my life was but I tried to write it to
make it seem like well we were trying to
be helpful
well I would I wouldn't do anything bad
I respect authority I guess I should say
and the idea of lying to the principal
okay
my boss is problematic I mean I
definitely not told the whole truth
but is that a lie someone say yes so
maybe I should say perhaps I don't speak
to the principal I've never spoken to
the I don't think I've ever been like
wait I don't even know his name
once never have I ever not read the book
before a lesson yep yeah you'd probably
see me at like 7:00 a.m. on my phone
looking at spark no it's like trying to
read the summary like as quick as I can
right before the class starts not
knowing exactly what was in the reading
but like hopefully pulling it all
together I will say that in my
experience as a student there were a lot
of times when we would get assigned
almost 100 pages of reading for like a
night or two and it was like dry
academic texts as a student might I
remember my dad bailing me out big time
once I totally dropped the ball did not
read whatever book I was supposed to
read so my amazing dad sat there with me
and he like read through it with me
quickly I was taking notes as he was
reading and he saved my butt the first
time I didn't do the reading was for
when we were reading Oliver Twist so I
go I go in and the first thing someone
says like did you guys actually do the
reading and then everyone's like no
that's the best way ever when nobody's
done the reading and then this poor
teacher is just sitting there like all
right so what did Oliver Twist's say to
the main
with the empty bowl after he ate pork
that's from the movie I haven't read the
book either never have I ever pretended
to be six like in this school yeah I
think I've done this more times than I
can count
I definitely have both as a student and
a teacher you know I mean you just need
a mental health day you know I just take
it an emotional day and I'll just call
in for that yep that's right I know what
I said before guess what this is what
this is where I said I'm sick today but
I've had another engagement so what's
really what I'm really saying is I'm not
feeling well emotionally and so I won't
be in today are you yet you have not I
have not because my mom I don't think
I've pretend to be sick if I don't want
to go then she just she'll say that like
I don't have to go
she's great like that no but you don't
do that all the time oh no definitely
not I still get like really worried
about what I miss I've definitely been
fooled by a student even though I work
with threes fours and fives they're
smart so there's a difference between I
think being fooled and just going along
with the charade you can't just be like
oh you're clearly not sick sit down
you're gonna stay in that chair because
you run the risk of what if they
actually are sick and then they boot it
all over their desk since they're so
young it's just kind of I'm impressed by
them you know I can't really get too
upset at it it's just like oh good job
little one you can almost tell right out
the gate if someone's actually feeling
sick or just a really good actor I mean
if they're if they're not even gonna
like commit to it they're not gonna
commit to like that oh I'm so sick okay
come on sick people don't act that way a
lot of students nowadays they try to do
like some sort of like trickery with
these teachers and instead they could be
studying
be like him just be like him I don't
think I fooled them but I tried to I was
in a musical I was talking to someone
else was the choreographer was speaking
and then he yelled at me for that and I
cried injustice oh I hate that I'm sorry
continue I cried and then in order to
cover that up I asked my theatre teacher
do you have any allergy pills because I
have allergies which probably just
embarrassed myself even further but it
was worth a shot
oh man I'm that's really good I should
use that nurse time I think we've had a
lot of we have a lot of similar answers
but yeah are you kidding me I feel like
Maddie and I see I don't know a lot of
things yeah and like we're both people
it's not just like we're so we
identified as student and teacher mm-hmm
we but we both why we both we both do
stupid things and like we both need to
take rest days and that's what being
human is all about
[Music]